place au sport maintenant est d'abord le
tennis à roland garros aujourd'hui la
grande attraction était le match du
jeune élève contre son modèle le match
de guy forget contre jimmy connors
connors a gagné en quatre manches mais
forget qui avait réussi à éliminer
nastase est parvenu à ravir un set à la
tête de série numéro un roger zabel un
cogneur jimmy connors c'est bien vous
allez voir sur cet échange que guy
forget n'a dans ce domaine rien à envier
à celui qu'il admire le plus et dont il
s'est sans doute inspiré
pour bien apprécier cette puissance nous
revoyons au ralenti les accélérations de
ce garçon de 17 ans qui pendant deux
jours aura fait vibrer le public de
roland garros après avoir perdu les deux
premières manches 6-2 6-3 cet après midi
guy forget s'est offert le luxe de
gagner la troisième au tie break
et ceci après avoir sauvé une balle de
match quand on est capable de jouer de
cette manière et de m jimmy connors à un
mètre de la balle
il est évident que l'on ne peut être que
promis à un très bel avenir
seulement dans une rencontre de tennis
de ce niveau c'est souvent l'expérience
qui prime et la jimmy connors n'en est
pas à son premier grand tournoi comme
c'est le cas pour son adversaire qu'il
bat finalement 6-2 6-3 6-7 6-1 après une
partie que guy forget abordés et
discutés sans aucun complexe
je suis rentré d'abord jeu en disant que
j'avais rien à perdre et que je vais
faire mes meilleurs matches donc je n'ai
pas à me soucier que ce soit jimmy
connors ce soit notre joueur donc
je suis entré dans notre révolte à
d'esprit pleine confiance en publiant un
grand court central malgré connors c'est
sûr qu'on y pense un petit peu
inconsciemment mais
et je suis de faire faire abstraction de
tout ça est ce que connors pour vous
reste le même après avoir joué contre
lui
oui il reste le même seulement moi
j'essaie de me dire que j'ai progressé
aussi donc c'est un petit peu normal que
que j'arrive à l'ennuyer un petit peu
mais pour moi ça sur quand même un grand
champion et le poster je vais arrêter
sur les murs de la chambre encore
toujours ce jour